[Music]
one day after the US Senate voted not to
remove the US president from office
Donald Trump was in the mood to
celebrate I've done things wrong in my
life I will admit not purposely but I've
done things wrong but this is what the
end result is Trump railed against
opposition Democrats who launched the
impeachment effort against him at times
using language that was derogatory and
profane it was all vote he tried to
coerce an ally into helping him cheat
Trump took aim at congressman Adam
Schiff who led the inquiry into whether
Trump abused his presidential powers by
withholding military aid to Ukraine in
an attempt to get them to investigate
his political rival former Vice
President Joe Biden a corrupt politician
named Adam Schiff made up my statement
to the Ukrainian president he brought it
out of thin air just made it up they say
he's a screenwriter a failed
screenwriter J Trump earlier in the day
at a National Prayer Breakfast Trump
also went after Mitt Romney who was the
only Republican senator who voted to
remove Trump from office he also lashed
out at House Speaker Nancy Pelosi I
don't like people who use their faith as
justification for doing what they know
is wrong Pelosi blasted the president in
response I pray hard for him because
he's so off the track of our
Constitution but throughout Trump's more
than an hour long remarks he repeatedly
maintained he committed no wrongdoing it
was a sharp contrast to President Bill
Clinton's more than a minute long
statement in 1999 following his own
impeachment acquittal I want to say
again to the American people how
profoundly sorry I am for what I said
and did to trigger these events
thank you Trump's only apology came not
to Americans but to his family who he
says has been caught up in allegations
and investigations since the start of
his presidency I want to apologize to my
family for having them have to go
through a phoney rotten deal
well the impeachment trial may be over
the allegations are not both Democrats
and Republicans are vowing to take this
case to American voters in November who
will ultimately decide if Donald Trump
is a 1 or 2 term president Kimberley
hellcat al Jazeera the White House